Regardez ce que j'ai trouvé dans le jardin : un ver !
Mais non pas celui-ci ! Un lombric.
Alors je sais, tout le monde n'aime pas ça
mais ce petit animal joue un rôle très important
dans notre écosystème.
Sans lui, on croulerait sous une montagne
de déchets organiques.
Les vers de terre dégradent cette matière
et la transforment en sels minéraux
que les plantes vont ensuite puiser avec leurs racines
et dont elles ont absolument besoin pour grandir.
Les vers de terre creusent également des galeries,
ce qui permet d'aérer le sol et facilite l'infiltration de l'eau et le déploiement des racines.
Leur rôle tellement important
que beaucoup d'agriculteurs ont renoncé aux labours pour préserver leurs sols.
Et je peux vous dire que ça bosse sous nos pieds.
On estime qu'il y a 200 vers de terre par mètre carré.
De quoi remplir une belle « capsule de déconfiné ».
Allez... on va à la pêche ?
Aux idées ! Parce que pour la pêche à la ligne,
il va falloir attendre un peu !
nous sommes confinés, mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette « capsule de déconfiné »,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain !